MARY POPPINS maybe practically perfect
in every way but Mary Poppins Returns
has made some interesting changes that
actually contradict some of the details
and events from the original movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
today i'm revealing six ways that Mary
Poppins returns ignored what happened in
the first film and I'll also explain why
some mild spoilers ahead though I avoid
any significant plot reveals a snow
globe with st. Paul's Cathedral played a
memorable part in the original movie
when Mary Poppins sang the lullaby feed
the birds to young Michael and Jane and
that snow globe pops up again in the
sequel along with the wooden letter
blocks and kite when the now adult
Michael is searching through the Attic
for something he's lost the snow globe
in this scene is used as a nostalgic way
to remind us and Michael of his time
with Mary Poppins and when he comments
that he doesn't know why they've kept
any of this stuff it shows us he's lost
his childlike wonder the problem with
this little easter egg though is that
it's almost impossible for Michaels to
still have that snow globe because in
the original movie Mary Poppins took it
with her when she left the banks family
yes the magical nanny actually put the
snow globe into her carpet bag together
with all her other belongings just
before her departure and unless she's
been making secret visits to Michael's
attic to hide snow globes there during
the 20 odd years since she was last in
Cherry Tree Lane then it shouldn't have
appeared there in the sequel when a
Robin accompanied Mary as she sang a
spoon for the sugar to the bank's
children in the original movie it was a
delightful little moment but as sweet as
that scene is it's also guilty of a goof
because despite the movies London
setting the Robin that perches itself on
Mary's fingers is an American Robin
which is much larger than the European
Robin found in England the sequel
actually fixes the original error via
the decorative Robin on Mary's hat which
this time around is a European Robin
with a much smaller red breast than its
American cousin so the new Robin isn't
just a fun Easter egg to a spoonful of
sugar was also a neat little way of
correcting that movie mistake from the
first film now we've got to talk about
how Emily Blunt has introduced a Mary
Poppins with a quite distinct character
to Julie Andrews version in the original
movie I think it's great that Blunt
decided to create her own Murray rather
than try an image
what Julie Andrews did because as blunt
herself has said no one is ever going to
out
Julie Julie Andrews I mentioned
previously in my comparison video how
Emily Blunt looked to author PL Travers
Mary Poppins books for inspiration and
in those books the magical nanny is much
more abrasive and ruder than the
generally more kind but firm character
so many of us grew to love in Julie
Andrews and that's why when Mary Poppins
comes back in the sequel she's got a
slightly weirder edge to her and you
could say she comes across as a bit
sharper we even see a somewhat more
risque side to Mary during her
performance of the song a cover is not
the book where she drops her new very
posh pronunciation for a cockney accent
and things lyrics laden with adult
humour the very prim and proper nanny we
met in the original movie is nowhere to
be found during this border villian song
and dance number in other words this is
not your childhood Mary Poppins when
Mary Poppins returns in the new movie so
does her talking umbrella but this time
around the parrot umbrella is quite
different first of all its colour has
changed from green to a deep almost
reddish brown colour and secondly it's
also a lot more chatty in the original
Mary Poppins film the umbrella was
silent throughout and only spoke at the
end to complain that the banks children
weren't grateful enough and to slightly
scold Mary for not admitting how much
she really cared about the family
practically perfect people never put its
sentiment to muddle their thinking so
I'll tell you one thing Mary Poppins you
don't fool me a bit oh really really I
know exactly how you feel about these
children
and if you think I'm gonna keep my mouth
shut any longer that will be quite
enough of that thank you I imagine many
people were pleasantly surprised when
the parrot certainly spoke for the first
time at the end of the 1964 film and I
think the creative team behind Mary
Poppins returns realised the comic
potential of giving the parrot umbrella
a bigger talking part this time around
so in the new movie the umbrella gets a
number of nice moments including some
choice comedic lines and a funny little
interaction with Dick Van Dyke which is
part of the plot however the parrots
replied that grownups forget they always
do when George Lee asked why his father
doesn't believe that Mary Poppins
arrived on a kite makes me think the new
film was also given the parrots
aspects of the talkative Jack Doran P L
Travers Mary Poppins books in the first
book for example the jackdaw tells two
of the bank's children that his kids
grow up they forget all about the
magical things that happened as for the
parents new look the movies production
designer has said about the film that we
want people to feel like they're seeing
something they've seen before but
they're really seeing it for the first
time
fun fact in the 1964 movie the parrot
umbrella was voiced by David Tomlinson
who also played the children's father
while in Mary Poppins Returns the voice
is provided by Edward Hibbert who's best
known as a snooty restaurant critic Gill
from the TV sitcom Frasier next it's
time to show how the sequels new
timeline has messed with Mary Poppins
age possibly confirming a popular fan
theory that Mary Poppins may well in
fact be a Time Lord for anyone who
doesn't know the first Mary Poppins
movie was set in 1910 and Julie Andrews
was 28 at the time of the US release
however Mary Poppins Returns is set in
the 1930s in depression-era London so
the events take place around 20 to 30
years after the first film Emily Blunt
though is only 35 just 7 years older
than Julie Andrews was at the time of
course actors don't just play their own
real age but generally have a certain
range within which they're able to play
convincingly
however whichever way you look at it
Emily Blunt doesn't look anything like
48 to 58 years old which is what Mary
Poppins would be based on Andrews age at
the time and if Mary Poppins at age 20
to 30 years like the time gap between
the two stories all in all it seems that
Mary Poppins is Burley aged even though
the Banks children have completely grown
up as has Jack who knew Mary when he was
a child
the sequel knows this anti-fur owns the
inconsistency making a joke of it good
heavens it really is you you seem hardly
to have aged at all
really how incredibly rude one never
discusses a woman's age Michael would
have hoped I taught you better
as for the official explanation the
movies producer mark platter said that
Mary's a character who lives outside of
time she's magic and so she is the one
character who actually doesn't age
Admiral boom and his first mate mr.
binnacle both return for what is
actually a slightly bigger part in the
sequel although the pair still fire
their cannon to mark the time in
MARY POPPINS returns as a running joke
about how they're no longer reliable
which is very different to the
reputation boom had built up about his
timekeeping in the original movie what
he's famous for is punctuality the old
world takes its time from Greenwich but
Greenwich they say takes its time from
Emerald boom when the sequel begins we
discover that boom and pinnacles cannon
fire now runs consistently late were
measured against Big Ben
although boom actually believes it's Big
Ben that's wrong while this is certainly
a change from the 1964 film if you've
seen the new movie or know that booms
time difference with Big Ben is part of
the plot though I won't spoil the
details and in a little further
explanation of this change the movies
novelization also adds that the Admiral
has slowed down in his later years and
his sense of time has slowed with him
while it's fun to spot these little
differences but you should know that
Mary Poppins never explains anything so
you can probably put these changes down
to Mary's magic now what do you think
were the best and worst part of the
sequel let me know in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this smash that
subscribe button and notification bell
so you don't miss any new videos next
tap left to find out all the amazing
details you missed in Mary Poppins
returns or tap right for another Mary
Poppins video you're sure to like thanks
for watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers